is kim kardashian ready to start dating
again
you just gotta roll with it a source is
opening up to et about the 40 year old
beauty mogul
revealing that while she's super focused
on her kids and brand
quote she wouldn't be fully opposed to
dating again if the right guy came along
down the line
the reality star filed for divorce from
husband kanye west in february
during the keeping up with the
kardashians reunion special she
addressed rumors that she was dating
colombian singer maluma
no i've seen him a few times always in
miami such a nice guy
so nice she also shut down reports of
dating attorney and political
commentator
van jones there are rumors that you're
dating van
van text me and was like this rumor has
gotten me so many dates
and i'm so grateful so no i'm not dating
either one not van jones not maluma
for now the source says kim and kanye's
four kids
north saint chicago and salm are doing
really well
adding that kim has always been a really
hands-on mom
who does a great job at balancing and
spending time with them
even when work gets busy quote family
time
is and always will be a huge priority to
her
at the end of the day life is about
being happy being
who you are and i feel like we are so
blessed to have the best support system
and the best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
and when it comes to co-parenting with
kanye it's all
smooth sailing according to the source
the former couple has been successfully
co-parenting their kids
both of them have been supportive of one
another and ultimately want what's best
for their little ones
and that support was on full display
last week
when kim and the kids were spotted at
kanye's donda
album listening event in atlanta
[Music]
and earlier this month the former couple
was spotted together in san francisco
with their kids
visiting the asian art museum a source
at the time told et that the entire west
fam was polite to the staff
and spent a lot of time in the museum's
new digital exhibition
it was a lot of fun as for kanye's love
life
our source says things between him and
rumored girlfriend
model irina shake are quote casual and
friendly
adding that irina isn't looking for
anything serious right now and
she's enjoying being single you'll
recall the 44 year old rapper and 35
year old model were spotted together
last month with a source telling e.t
at the time that they've been friendly
for a while she even starred in the
music video
for his 2010 hit single power
[Music]
fast forward to 2021 and we're told
kim was never bothered by kanye and
arena spending time together
at the end of the day the source says
kim wants kanye to be happy
you